this used to be the office
and uh this side of the i think all of
the apartments were much more
badly effective from this side
and how long did this all take to happen
instantly i mean just it was
a fire on the horizon which could have
been anything
and i wasn't really aware of uh or
thinking about too much
into a blast in split seconds
[Music]
i remember actually in the living room i
was
on the phone and
i felt the ground tremble here and very
shaky
that's when i first saw that it's
combined earthquake
i'm sure everyone has the old earthquake
but it can't be this heavy
uh and then within a split second i
found myself just
falling to the floor and the next thing
i remembered was getting up
and my neighbor who has a i think
one-year-old son came into my house sort
of wailing very panicked
sort of asking for help asking someone
to call her husband
um i kind of went over there and made
sure that they were okay
she was trembling so she handed me her
her child
and then we managed to sort of calm each
other down to be fair and
head down the fire escape down to the
ground level
oh my god
it's difficult to really think about
material damage and what is essentially
superficial damage when
so many thousands of people uh have been
severely injured and dozens of people
have died
people had a lot worse you've seen it
this morning we've gone into areas in
germany and near the port where
houses have caved in and flats are
totally decimated
and what about lebanon do you think
because you've covered this area
you've lived in this country for a while
it's very sad my parents are lebanese
they came to london
uh in the late 1970s to escape civil war
like
most lebanese people they're very proud
of their country there's lots that they
love about their country
and i was brought up with a very keen
sense of identity
and and pride in in what my my
background was it's very very difficult
to see the country in such a state it's
very painful to see your friends and
family suffering like they are
it's very painful to see such
inefficiency and inability to get things
right
and to provide services for people to
allow people to live ordinary lives
and it is it's almost
i mean you couldn't write it that in
the midst of the worst economic crisis
this country has ever
gone through when so many people are so
desperate
and a health crisis on top that you'd
have this kind of
disaster it's really upsetting